my name is Alex I'm here with Edie who's
in the back and will join us in the
middle of the talk we're both from
Google brain the SAR team as you joint
work with Tim Frasca who's a professor
at MIT Jeff Dean and alkies Poly's
Odie's for both also at Google and this
work really is about database systems in
particular but I think this has
interesting implications for any system
that sort of is running on data doing
operations over data and really for all
of these they're these sort of
fundamental building blocks that we've
all learned about and sort of rely upon
in any of these systems everything from
sorting and joins is sort of key
operations it's a data structures like
beech trees and bloom filters that are
well studied for decades now one thing I
found interesting as a more ml data
mining person coming into sort of the
world of infrastructure is the degree to
which infrastructure is really built as
a this is one size fits all we should
have one PJ instructor that really
should work for a huge number of
applications and this essentially is
interesting Lee in contrast I think to
the ways in which much of machine
learning focuses a lot of attention on
individual applications and to defect of
yeah we cited a DML side you know I was
not I came in an 89
sorry soapy trees obviously I've been
well-studied to give some background of
I'm guessing us when the room or do you
know this you say you have this huge
array of data right there's a bunch of
keys when some payload over that data
that we're trying to do lookups on and
we build this tree with some branching
factor that will help us efficiently go
from the root node to find that data and
then you can do a range query data
sorted so you find the starting point in
the range and you walk through this
array now this is a good idea general
purpose it has nice properties in terms
of cache efficiency tons of useful
things what happens if your data though
is all integers from 0 to 1 million you
can see this here done on the slide at 0
to 480 right so in this case you really
need the tree structure I mean the tree
will work just fine but it's kind of
besides the point
right you can just do a direct look up
with the key if it was from a hundred to
a hundred million hundred as the range
you could do lookup key minus 100 right
so for pretty simple patterns we can see
obviously that the B tree is overkill
can do it in oh of one lookup time of
one memory in those cases these corner
cases so this one-size-fits-all thing
while it works it's also overkill right
it's not really the best fit on the flip
side we don't want to go and check every
time we build a data set does it meet
one of these sort of properties we
expect and therefore we can use as other
data base and the cool thing is machine
learning lets us think about this over
distributions more generally kind of
abstract away that concept of
consecutive integers and say even for
these other patterns that may not be
quite as simple we can still aim to do
that same thing the kind of simplified
lookup the pattern and this is the key
insight it's the switch from thinking
about this as sort of the data as a
black a black box that we're operating
over and we think about scaling in terms
of just how many items are in that data
set to thinking about the data
distribution right how noisy is the
state of distribution or how complicated
the distribution and not just the size
and this can actually escaped me a
change the ways in which we design these
algorithms so I really think honestly
this has implications for tons of things
and we since we we started working on it
and we increasingly find new places
where this can affect the way we think
about the design but we're gonna go
through a couple cases and really be
trees in a ton of detail i'm hashmaps
and blue filters in some detail and we
can sort of opine on on where it has
effects for things like sorting and
joins but start with boot b-trees as an
example right so as I mentioned this is
this tree structure and the real reason
this is a huge benefit over things like
binary search in practice because it
matches well the actual systems that
these databases are run on right there
is a cache hierarchy and B trees are
well-suited for that and we can tune
things like the branching factor to
match page sizes etc but sorry for that
looping thing but we see a beech tree
really just this input/output property
right they see the input the key and
outputs really a page right in practice
these are usually store on disk so
here's this page it lies on this page
and then usually we do some search
within the page to find exactly where in
that page the the key the record lies so
abstracting further we can say this is a
general mapping right key to position
and then within then we know that the
record with that key lies in the range
from position to position Plus page size
if we abstract one more step we see this
can be pretty loose we just need some
function to magically go from key to
position and at least as long that
positions pretty close and we kind of
know how close it is we can say at the
worst that's overshooting by this much
and the worse that's undershooting by
this much then we can search in that
range and find the exact right record
and one cool thing that came out once
you frame it this way is that you find
that what the beech tree is really doing
its building a model of the cumulative
distribution function right so if your
data is a sample from a Gaussian as here
you find that most of your data will
come in this
or narrow range in the middle and as a
result it will sort of allocate more
parts of the tree there to understand
that but the cool thing is people in ml
and statistics have been studying CDF's
for a long time we can leverage a lot of
that understanding as interesting
properties like a skew monotonic and
other constraints on the modeling but
the point is this is a pretty general
purpose model that really just at the
core describing what's the distribution
of your data where is it coming from how
does it look and so we had this idea and
we thought okay this seems like a cool
new thing what do we do with this right
and there's all these reasons we were
excited they should be much smaller
models are tiny by comparison to be
trees right maybe it'll be faster if you
can do folding point operations instead
of if statements we can do parallelism
we can do batches of operations at a
time
obviously GPUs and TP use are on the
rise right so you know all these hopes
for what this would do right so this was
we were really excited about the work at
the start and we said okay let's just do
the ML thing we'll just throw tensorflow
at the problem and say it'll just figure
it out right this is the ML magic so we
have 200 million records
we'll say look I'll take a two layer
neural network and just sort of typical
fully connected thing trained it to
predict the position given the key these
are integers it's pretty pretty normal
beat reruns on the order of 300
nanoseconds this first version ran in
80,000 nanoseconds right so this was
kind of a bit of a step back so two
steps forward one step back kind of
situation right we thought okay yeah
this huge breakthrough and insight
we'll just do it and then it doesn't
work and the more we spend time with
this we found there's tons of pieces to
this problem that I think are actually
fascinating directions on the system
side as well as on the ml side for one
thing tensorflow really is not it's the
data set size is 200 million keys but
we're measuring here the time to run the
index so in the Petrie case it's just
walking through the tree and the model
really this is just instantiating
tensorflow
effectively it's I mean it's independent
of the size of the data
right yeah the beautifully doesn't it's
not even close yeah there's a size of
data that would have made this come
close there is obviously but yeah I
think the thing it was is that
tensorflow really is not designed for
that size of operations or anything
we're moving in that direction there
becomes increasingly sort of efforts to
make it work for example on on varieties
of hardware and to have it handle
different performance requirements but
generally like you looking at can we
analyze searches and recommendation
systems which is another area of others
areas of research that I work on there
you see that it's just different orders
of magnitude right so come into like
what actually is happening I don't think
it's a good that is by far anyway not
the best that we could do I think with
out-of-the-box tools now even from a
year ago when we ran that but it was
definitely not like the most thorough
study of that I think we just like if
you do the standard thing it won't work
obviously there's tons of work on GPUs
that are trying to make that faster
those are generally throughput focused
different different constraints for
different systems so there's pure speed
there's actually model structure right
b-trees virtually really good at
overfitting it turns out and that's
usually like a bad word in ml you don't
want to over fit it turns out for
databases that's that she's not so bad
in many cases right if you're a read
only database I know the data I know
exactly what I'm trying to - there's
nothing else outside to generalize over
cache efficiency I don't think I've ever
heard of a paper for ML thinking about a
cache efficient designed model there's a
lot of work now going into matching the
hardware for things like GPUs but this
is sort of a new problem and then search
right at the I mentioned at the end
there's this process of actually have to
to search over normally in the page but
here could be much larger possibly or
much more narrow right it can vary you
don't know how accurate the model is and
so there's questions like what's the
best search style give it an approximate
answer so I'll kind of go through a few
of these things we've tried to tackle so
for one thing is speed right here
essentially we wanted to go from using
raw tensorflow
to just sort of compiled operations
right so we can learn you stencil to
learn a model extract the weights and
then have that sort of better organized
in memory in terms of the weights you'll
see in a few slides how there's
different pieces to them also organized
as well as actually have those
operations being run in like raw igan
which is with underneath log the
tensorflow but but in simpler operations
there's obviously things like a B X s if
we didn't actually or seemed DVI she
didn't even make use of a lot of this
builds on work team had done previously
on compiling ahead of time database
operations and so I think there's a lot
of potential here generally for ml to
sort of catch up for doing these really
really low latency kind of things next
wish became like what is accurate enough
when is it even worthwhile to use a
model in the first place and we'd spent
a long time debating does it matter to
have the bottom of the tree be accurate
or the top of the tree be accurate or
where do we think it actually is
beneficial and here's some like rough
math that you have you have a hundred
million records and your typical let's
say page size or branch factor 64 and
that gets you from essentially knowing
it's in this 100 million records so it's
in this give or take 1.5 million records
right and so pretty much if you can get
a model that can be more accurate than
being the right 1.5 million range
that's probably worthwhile and you can
see that at every level right and
there's a horses challenge right they
take 60 cycles for that for that thing
to actually do this search within that
page within that branch and know which
branch to take so we have to have fewer
in 60 cycles of modeling time used to
actually figure out that 1.5 million
record range we can do this in I've seen
each level and they becomes like a how
big models we make all right so what's
the right model which I do a super-wide
model so okay people know that these are
supposedly universal function
approximator is just make it super wide
and it should be able to model anything
and this will then talk
in terms of math operations two times
the width of this where we can say okay
well deep is actually better for
complicated patterns so it's in this
case with squared in terms of the the
width of the layer and you can say for
every intermediate layer you have to do
like it's that square matrix right so
that's an additional matrix math we have
to do now the problem with this is we
found is a doing a single model is good
but not great we really want to be able
do is make use of the memory right do
one of these models is tiny compared to
a b-tree right that that's like the gap
is huge but we want to develop move in
that in between those two things a bit
more elegantly right we should all say I
want to ramp up the model size and with
that not totally kill my speed and at
the same time improve my accuracy
greatly and this became a sort of this
design space challenge we had to figure
out and so we used this idea called
hierarchy of experts it's there's a
bunch of literature on modeling at
multiple experts in ml this is a
structure being used in particular where
we say I can have a very small model
even a linear model to try to say given
a key predicted position and I train it
sort of in the typical way predicted
position and then given that approximate
position use that to select another
model and that model that be trained on
the subset of data that was thought to
be in that range right so you're slowly
doing is you're whittling down similar
to a b-tree the amount the range of data
that each model is expected to model
well and we can do this over and over
again recursively until we sort of get
these models that are sort of
approximating less and less data well
you really do feel the linear models for
example you're getting these piecewise
linear function but we don't to do this
sort of search over which piece we're in
it's selecting it through this sequence
of multiplications and the good part of
this is the decouples entirely the model
size and its complexity in terms of what
it can model effectively
you're treating that whole thing as one
model we trained it stage wise so within
the top layer first that can be like a
linear model when pass so yet
independent agents linear each one each
stage is one pass over the data so you
do one pass you find out then the next
one which bucket it would fall into and
train that on one pass if it's non
linear it's obviously a little more
complicated but still you do stage wise
dari we've tried some things but
actually training it end-to-end there's
some interesting challenges so the
related work here is the mixture of
experts work where they'll train a
softmax over different models but that's
inefficient if you have large numbers
we'll see we go up to a hundred thousand
sub models in some cases
so once you've a soft max youth actually
now search what's the max in that soft
max that's slow we're here we're doing
listen to your regression prediction
right we're saying this is the index of
the model I want to look up and for that
you definitely know add some variance in
order to do some searching over and it
gets complicated so I think there's
potential there but at this point this
was like good enough just I have
expression when you go come down into
hierarchy does it mean that the training
set becomes smaller yeah each model
becomes now it's handling a much more
narrow region it's a problem that you're
over fitting for our overfitting because
only the data in the database we have to
index this is like an these cool things
that we won over fit this is why the
model looks quite different from what
everyone does in traditional neural
networks is it guaranteed that you that
prediction of the top level model will
like the range that it predicts will
include the actual here it's not
printing arrange its printing in numbers
and so it could be pretty far off so we
we can do because again it's a fixed
size data set we can look at essentially
how far off were we so one pass train
the models I can pass
look at how wrong where we possibly in
that pass Oh in that trained model and
we can use that now to to narrow down
case we can say look I didn't really do
it well enough right I see there's a big
error and I can substitute out saying it
for whatever reason there's some pattern
here that just I can't get right
fall back I think a lot of the work will
come to is there's this hybrid pattern
right where ml can provide a very good
approximation for a large number of the
cases but B not every case and using
this in combination with traditional
data structures makes it sort of give
the guarantees you want while getting a
lot of benefit so we have a bunch of
slides later but it's a open question
right so we only tested at least
empirically so far the the question of
if was read only it's not read only you
could leave space and say okay the
montane less accurate I'll just degrade
gracefully which would be not the end of
the world your error estimates go away
um we can deal with that in a few slides
you can imagine doing training again
again that's gonna kill your error
estimates and depending on how you do
that training it could affect how well
it's doing so there's a huge design
space there of what's possible I'll go
into more detail but I think there's a
bunch of like interesting questions so
one more question so the question is it
we have a pretty good prediction but we
need to do this sort of last mile issue
that should go from approximate answer
to getting you the right data you
actually asked for so I can say there's
some pretty wide error bars here and I
can do the typical binary search thing I
know the min error and the max error and
then I can slowly walk through from the
predicted position until I find the
right point now the problem with this of
course is that we were actually really
close and now we wasted a lot of time
trying to do this full range search and
so a lot of us do with then trade-offs
depending on how accurate your model is
and what your air distribution looks
like to matching your search algorithm
with that so we can duke ordinary search
this is a swing tune played with a bit
where we look at a standard deviation
and we add multiple predictions around
it and we can move all these
simultaneously efficiently this is not
the most cleared I'll show some how that
works but essentially you can slowly
hone in and the last thing say if we
don't know the errors so I think is
actually a useful case because in many
cases things like inserts my dish drawer
destroy our error estimates in this case
we can still do sort of exponential
search right so I have this prediction
and I just slowly move step by step away
and so I overshoot and go back right so
you overshoot here and now I can slowly
walk back to the right place so it's
pretty flexible in terms of like there's
mobile search strategies with different
properties they do we'll see a couple
experiment results that do show that
they have some trade-off spanned the
model but overall it wasn't like a
make-or-break part of what made it
succeed so we tested on four different
data sets with real patterns so when
it's a time stand data set from some
server logs longitude from maps some
ones like the most linear so she gets
the best results this is a synthetic
data from a log normal distribution
right so in this case we know it's
nonlinear and then string documents
strings have their own issues because
kind of arbitrary in many ways and their
document IDs so I'll give some structure
to them at least watch the choke collar
steena but Berkeley and that's question
is basically a lot of progress was made
simply because
improvements in device physics and the
database people made a distinction
between in court databases where
everything was in memory versus off core
you know on secondary storage devices
and totally recently and we had solid
state disks to replace rotating media
sample sorry you can you get into
databases with address that's larger
than 32 bits so there's it's a good
question there's two points to that I
would say one is the question of how did
the model deal with large address spaces
and the second becomes how does how do
we deal with actually not being able to
assume that the end location is ordered
right so if you have pages that are on
disk those might not actually be in
order or they've been separate devices
like that right in terms of the disk
based part we have some preliminary
ideas that we can't sort of give
empirical numbers for yet but there is
in terms of the the there's also the
issue of like most models aren't dealing
with like really large numbers and you
guys obviously have to scale them like
your operations to be able to handle
that but I think even that also is not
quite as bad it's manageable it's an
engineering issue sure yes these are
definitely not your all in memory tests
we ran so the course of the question is
obviously doesn't work this is on the
the Maps data I believe yep the master
data and we see the b-tree this was the
best beach resize the page 128 for the
particular device we were testing on and
we ran this with linear models in this
case so each model in this trees a
linear model but we see the second stage
size is a huge effect on to the
performance right so there's one key
root node of a linear and then followed
by many many small models the second
node saint layer
it's how many models there are each
model is linear so there's a bias and a
slope okay so if you give me the bolded
ones 50,001 and how big are each of your
models parameters it's a linear model so
it's a single floating-point number and
a bias term so two floating point
there's just two parameters for you
learn about yeah we did there's some
other results that go through nonlinear
models that pays off especially in the
string case other things but I think it
turns out the hierarchy is actually very
powerful compared to like when you
reduce a bigger neural network for the
usual one
so having a mini a larger tree seems to
be the right choice and we do see here
there's this trade-off essentially you
make the number of models in second
layer larger obviously makes the actual
thing itself larger we generally see
that uses the time so you have this
trade-off between memory and latency in
some ways I think this is nice I think
this generally what we get with the
model approach learning approach you
actually have some nice ability to move
more cleanly in the space of let me use
more memory decrease latency and change
and also trade-off actual compute and I
can actually moving that's okay think
much more flexibly depend on how I
design my mouse structure itself what
I'm willing to deal with and so we do
find in something scary we can get to be
one one hundredth the size or multiple
times as fast which i think is a nice
thing given this is like all from that
earlier 80,000 nanosecond this
commensurate 308 are seconds we didn't
look closely any times for linear models
is pretty fast it's again single pass so
this would be I think like a four passes
at most including the error computation
and that could be all done in the learn
the LIF system actually does the
training there you although linear stuff
was done sort of in process whereas a
nonlinear model you use tensor flow and
offload it generally wasn't a huge
concern and a lot of systems that like
we work with have a separate triggered
model construction time when it's a
read-only system
so is this like adverbs lookup time or
is it the others are there six about how
it performs in the worst case we did
look at it I can't remember the details
honestly and there was a we did look at
like different percentile marks remember
the details unfortunately we also didn't
really look at in anyway this is another
assumption and it's worth mentioning
this assumes the sort of uniform query
distribution right so we're not also
optimizing for some preference for one
part of date over the other it's only
looking it's the same amount information
that a b-tree has over all we get sort
of these these levels improvements occur
several data sets the the map stated I
think does the best because it's the
most linear and so it's an easiest to to
model and you do see I think this is
interesting property right that don't
know how complicated the data is yeah
are that affects how well we can do on
it we under the current model class for
looking at strings are present the
biggest challenge they can be a sort of
arbitrary word length and the
computation needed to deal with it is
not great there's much other details
about how to actually model strings
right people model them typically for
language purposes not for the sort of
index lookup in ml and so this is an
example of that where we actually start
to find that using things like the
coronary search has the biggest has a
decent impact actually and some of these
hybrid index to start to matter right so
we do find that in these harder cases
these extra steps do end up paying off
whereas in the earlier maps case sort of
out of the box modeling works pretty
well I mean well obviously with the
compilation everything else there's also
a bunch of discussion afterwards about
like what's the right baseline and how
would you actually take this insight
using other places right so someone
suggested for example using a fixed size
B tree and then you can do interpolation
search afterwards right into these
different combinations of these ideas so
we tested this on this log normal Dana
synthetic data the payload size affects
how well does this affects cache
efficiency but ultimately we end up
seeing that that we can still always
find through a better balancing of both
memory and latency this partially also
makes use of using a multivariate model
right so we can look at things like the
square of the key and that helps give
some more flexibility beyond just a
linear model both increasing the model
itself more complicate a significant way
in complexity I think that again by no
means is this the end-all be-all of
models I think there's just in a big
open area to make better models for this
kind of system yeah and that's just a
visualization of that and last thing I
think this is but yet by no means sort
of a deep theoretical analysis but I
think it's nice to think about under
this ml perspective what would theory
look like right and so here I looked at
saying if we have its empirical CDF it's
kind of flip from the way you normally
think about CDF style analysis and
statistics say I have the empirical CDF
that is the ground truth right I need to
model that as well as possible but if
you imagine that the model of it is the
theoretical CDF that it was sampled from
and say well that they're closely up
isn't any more complicated but we do say
is that it has some accuracy there's
some noise inherent in a sampling
process but it's a reasonably good
accurate model it's not overfitting
unfortunately but we can find
essentially as the data size grows that
affects the accuracy and this is happens
to be a way that accuracy sort of works
out this expected squared error between
the empirical CDF and theoretical CDF
scales 1 over N but if we're now
multiplying this by n we're right we
have to look up in an N size data set
that means the the error in that look up
it scales with oh of square root of n so
I don't think this is particularly the
best way or even the most charitable way
of analyzing what we're doing I think it
does provide a path forward thing about
okay how do we think about the
distribution and the difficulty of it
and how that affects the scalability of
our algorithm
and it sends two open questions inserts
is obviously one of the ones that you
always bring up
if yours potential right so a pens is a
whole class of problem so you have time
stamps that are being inserted so sort
of sequential data that's coming in
chances are those pretty consistent
patterns where you can imagine they're
sort of cyclical daily patterns if we
can generalize an ml studies a ton about
how you generalize into the future it's
possible we actually can do this without
having to build out your index over time
and there's less yep so the idea here
would be to say if I have one model that
can generalize into the future which is
what ml mostly tries to do we don't
actually need to keep constructing the
model right I don't have to keep
building the b-tree as I insert data and
so I'm Lily's going to be adding data
inserting it at the end of my the next
page on disk so I still do the writing
to disk I still have to or adding it to
the end of the array
but the model should hopefully still be
able to predict as n grows just predict
into the future it could still be at
noon as peak time and at 6:00 a.m. is is
quiet time and that's the cyclical
pattern I have to put it into the future
and I'll have some error and I'll can do
search to correct that at the end right
if you're indexing on timestamp
[Music]
I think the key thing I'm saying is if
it's a case where you want to be ordered
by timestamp which is a set of property
like give me all the indexed thing is
coming in in order and I don't need to
know as I say append-only right not
arbitrary inserts here
so arbitrary inserts you could say I can
leave space in my sorted array b-trees
can do this - you can leave space
obviously and then hope that space is
well allocated and that if the space is
well allocated such as the pages don't
fill up I can just sort of keep things
in order in the page and the b-tree
above it can stay the same but when I
spell over pages I have to now do some
reshuffling of the internals of the tree
and the hope here becomes well maybe I
can use being smarter in this way again
in the modelling side it can be
approximate ml has a lot of work again
on generalize in the future looking
covariant shifts and saying not just
where is there what says you should nap
distribution now but where I think it's
gonna grow in the future and I'll leave
space there and I think again this is
not by any means that we've done this
but there's the the language of ml or
they sort of head towards been done in
the past could be adapted in useful ways
to try to deal with this issue and so
now turn over to Ed moving on from
b-trees to some other structures in the
beginning we started showing this
picture right to give you a sense of all
the various possible data structures
that we might be interested in affecting
using this learn index idea and Alex
just spent all this time basically
taking you through this particular use
case of B trees but what about other
kinds of data structures for example
hashmaps
now it's actually kind of interesting
we're telling this story a little bit in
reverse chronological order because we
started with obviously something a
little simpler and we told you actually
the most complicated case and hashmap
was actually the second one we looked at
and we'll talk about bloom filters later
but if you think about a hash map keys
basically our map to a position inside
an array right so that's the prediction
task that essentially that we care about
now if it turns out that spot is taken
in that array what we do is we do a
linked list overflow right so collisions
unfortunately in hash map
actually really expensive because you're
basically doing pointer chasing and
every pointer that you chase is actually
about 100 nanoseconds using the current
architectures so you know we want to
avoid that collision as much as possible
that's essentially the the job of what a
hash map is trying to do right so if we
think about hashmaps
essentially as a learned model now the
same ideas that we were talking about in
the B tree case actually applies as well
so basically a machine learning model in
this case is kind of learning
essentially the the CDF the cumulative
distribution function right and we can
directly actually use that learned
function as our hash right so in that
case if you have perfect information
about your data which in a way we do
because we know every single key that we
care about in the hash map and then a
perfect CDF model would give us zero
collisions right and and this goes back
to the question I think you were asking
about a little bit before is that if we
assume that we're only doing reading
then at that moment in time we have the
perfect information and therefore
there's no collision but of course with
inserts you end up with more and more
collisions right now what's interesting
about this is that this fact that if you
have the perfect CDF at that moment in
time you can construct the perfect a
lookup table essentially right is
independent of any kind of modification
that you want to do to the hash map
right whatever kind of hash map type you
might want to use so the question is is
whether this is really true so you know
like like good researchers when we
started thinking about okay hashmaps
we wanted to build a essentially the
quickest bench benchmark that we can to
rapidly reduce whether we have a
difficult problem here or not so we
tried this idea on three different data
sets on the map data I think alex has
talked about a little bit before the web
data I think will get actually get into
a little bit more
later in the slides and then just some
arbitrary lognormal distribution that we
created so you can see that in the
traditional hash map you get collision
rates roughly in the thirty five percent
range whereas this alert model you can
drop dramatically reduce the number of
collisions in in the MA in in the
lookups so that reduction looked pretty
pretty dramatic to us it was like oh
that's good news you know we should
chase after this idea maybe this ideas
wasn't so terrible after all so that was
very encouraging early on when we were
starting to look at hash maps when we
look deeper into this so the data I'm
showing here is basically you build a
hash map and you either use a random
hash function or you used the learned
model hash that we learned through
through the procedure that we described
you can see that the amount of empty
slots that we end up having to use has a
pretty dramatic reduction in the amount
of space that we need for those empty
slots and yes space is the model the
model itself cost oh that's a good
question the model themselves are
actually very very cheap right because
you would basically just need to know
the CDF right like the CDF is what
you're you're learning yeah exactly
so it's it's super cheap as a result
right
the interesting thing here is that you
can see that at least in our
implementation and compared to a random
hash the the model actually you have
some little bit of computation to do and
that that cost you a couple of
nanoseconds and so it's actually not
true in this particular case where the
render we can beat the random hash as a
function yes if you're assuming that the
distribution in your data is pretty much
fixed and you know the keys mm-hmm why
learn it why not just
you know in a sensor of a tablet just
tablet it completely right yeah you know
that's interesting because in a way it
connects to your question about inserts
earlier in the particular case of
hashmaps we as we are thinking about the
transaction where you're inserting these
items right so if if it's truly
completely a static world where you know
all the keys ahead of time
you you're right in a sense that you
just tablet the the CDF and just use
that function right the size is kind of
an issue a learn model my actually
compress me you have a for example if
you had a linear function right that's
literally two parameter as Alex was
saying before that's much smaller and as
storing the entire CDF so you may have
heard about a little bit of the
controversy around this paper and there
were a little bit of conversation online
about whether we're comparing against
the stadia our hash map implementations
and whatnots and so one the interesting
thing about this space is that you could
use various different kinds of
assumptions about what kind of
instructions that you're using what kind
of hashing technique you're using etc so
we ran the the experiments after some of
the the code were made available to us
looking at for example the the Avs
instruction says how much payload you're
actually using and things like that in
our experiments we see that in for
particularly in the in place chain
hashmaps
with the assumption of using a 20-byte
as the payload that you're looking up
the learned hash function actually
achieves very very good performance of
about 35 nanoseconds compared to some
other implementations so we we do
think that it the soundest ideas seems
to hold up under some scrutiny and the
space utilization and obviously also
very good because again you know the
basic idea here is that since you have
perfect information on CDF why wouldn't
you be able to do better
so let me touch upon a little bit on
bloom filters yes yeah that's a toast oh
right you mean instead of running the
four PI values I think that the reason
that we were really thinking about is
that we think that the four PI case is
not really all that realistic in the
real real world workload right I mean
that's a very very small payload I think
I remember the first to fix the cache
essentially the options I mean the
larger record can only slow you down he
wouldn't make you right so a four byte I
would imagine would be less should be
less than 35 nanoseconds right yeah so
you could be still 35 days where you're
saying yeah I mean that's reasonable
assumption I think thinking about this
space one major challenges as you kind
of are pointing out is is why the water
you're hitting the same cache line or
not yeah that's right
so you know that kind of thing sometimes
I even depend on your your workload
assumptions and things like that right
so let me actually tell the story around
bloom filters because to some extent
this is actually the story that I love
the most because
this was the place where we actually
started when we started thinking about
learning disease and it's a part that I
feel like I also have more of a hand in
it
so in just just as a quick summary of
what bloom filters are right so what
bloom filters are basically is you give
it a key and you ask it whether this key
exists in your index or not and so what
bloom filters are nice is that they
guarantee that the false negatives is or
is essentially false the unit rate is
zero and you can sort of tune your
performance of your traditional bloom
filter by choosing as a false positive
rate that you're willing to tolerate
basically when it says yes how often it
is actually wrong about being being yes
so how a bloom filter works in in in a
traditional way is in the following way
so you take a key and you have multiple
hash functions that you apply to that
key and then you have this bit array
that basically serves as a lookup right
so doing insert when you're inserting
your particular key you hash that key
and you have those bit positions and you
turn those bits to one right and doing a
lookup or a probe what you do is you
take that that key that you want to look
up and you apply that those same set of
hash functions and you look in those bit
positions if any one of them is a zero
you will return now right if they're all
ones and then you will return yes so
that's how bloom filters work but if you
think about what it is trying to do from
machine learner perspective which by the
way is that's what I guess at this point
I can call myself a machine learning
researcher I'm wearing a Google AI sure
so I guess I am a machine learning guy
you know actually that just as a side
note the last time I was in this room
was Terry Winograd inviting me to give a
talk here and I was back then known as a
web analytic and social computing guy so
you know like you can reinvent your
career right
but if you think about bloom filters as
a model and then all they are is really
a blank binary classification task
that's all right
you give it a key and he needs to
predict whether is inside this set or
outside of this set and that's it the
big problem with that view is that the
false negatives are not guaranteed in a
typical binary classification machine
learned model so how do you solve that
problem and this is the part that I'm
pretty proud of because when when Tim
was interning in my team he was doing
his sabbatical in my team we were
discussing this problem and I suggested
that we could use a spillover bloom
filter so the idea of course is that if
it says no what you can do is you and
then double check it using a bloom
filter but the beauty of it is that this
beautiful bloom filter can be much much
smaller because you've taken care of all
the other keys that you don't need to
know about a century there are the easy
cases so the the bloom filter becomes
this guarantee that deals with only the
HAR cases I think this design patterns
really interesting is that it's sort of
unfortunately I know the somebody in in
the seus department Chris Manning who's
actually kind of a acquaintance of mine
you know sort of talked about the talked
up this paper a little bit and it some
people start saying oh store away your
database or a data structure textbooks
but actually we were we never sit that
really in the paper in fact part of the
paper was saying make use of the
traditional data structure along with
learning decks right at the same time
they can actually work hand-in-hand the
beauty of the traditional loan filter is
that it gives you this guarantee
essentially of the false negatives being
zero the false positive rate is zero so
this solution of having a spillover is
is something that I think is a design
pattern in these kind of learning index
situations that we can make use of in
other kinds of we just talked about all
the other data structures that
can conceivably use this idea on so
there may be these patterns in those
other data structures as well so here's
some results again you know we wear
every time we think about an idea like
this we want to rapidly reduce to see
whether we're wrong right this is the
idea holding water and so in this
particular case we're plotting on the
y-axis the memory footprint the size of
the model in this case we build
basically what the task that we're
trying to do is you have URLs that are
held in a database and we want to find
out whether those URLs are good or bad
they're they're bad when they're a
fishing URL so and then we want to warm
the user basically but you're good if
they're not in our database
right and so the y-axis is applauding
the memory footprint the wire the x-axis
is the false positive rate you can see a
traditional bloom filter in red here the
top line and then the various versions
of our model which are built using RN
ends and the W refers to how wide the
RNN model is how many neurons wide it is
and then the e refers to the embedding
size that's used as the vocabulary
underneath the RNN so you can see that
different size in terms of the machine
learning model you get slightly
different performance but they're
actually pretty close to each other the
120a is a little bit over capacity of
over capacity so you can see that it's
memory footprint goes up a little bit
but 32 or 16 is more than enough for the
tasks that we were looking at and that
resulted in a 36 percent reduction in
memory for this particular bloom filter
now we after we put the initial version
of this paper on archive as you can
imagine lots of people started writing
emails to us one of them was Michael
Mitchell mocker from Harvard University
who have been spending essentially a
majority part of his career on bloom
filters so as you can imagine
when he was alerted that we were
interested in bloom filters he was very
curious about our results we ended up at
having a very very long email thread
back and forth about whether to learn
index learn bloom filters is a good idea
or not and eventually we're happy to say
that that he came around to our point of
view and in fact not only da he had an
additional build on our idea of this
spillover bloom filter he said why not
also use another simple bloom filter in
front of the learned model and and
create a sandwich structure so you run
through the initial bloom filter first
again handling some really easy cases
and then have the learn model handled
kind of the medium hard cases and the
really hard models end up in us in an
additional spillover at the bottom and
he was able to prove recently that it
was an additional 12% saving in size and
sound workloads that he was looking at
so I think that paper is now available
online right so so that kind of gives
you a sense of three cases of the
various things that we're looking at so
one thing that we spend a little bit of
time discussing already in this form is
inserts and updates how do we deal with
inserts and updates and trees you know
this is one of those annoying tricks
that lecturers and professors like to do
is you know that exercises left to the
reader right so inserts and updates I
think there's some real opportunities to
do some research there but there are
lots of other potential applications so
for example we haven't talked about at
all about joints
how do you do joins well and and in fact
one the most tricky problems in joints
is the problem of estimating the
cardinality if you can do that using a
learned approach you might be able to do
much more efficient joints sorting is
pretty interesting that's obviously had
been a lot of work
that has gone into beating the best
sorting algorithms out there we think
that there might be an opportunity to
use a learned approach for sorting the
CDF essentially gives you a proximate
sort order so there may be an
opportunity to again you know make use
of that information and maybe combine
with some traditional sorting algorithms
in that sort of maybe sandwich or not
sandwiched approach unit that combine
hybrid approach to really kind of look
at sorting in some some some new lens
using this the the formula that we given
in this lecture another really
interesting thing that that we have
started working on simply because it's
just so fascinating is that you can
think of a lot of the work that we have
described here as being wanting to
create a mapping function right and it's
typically 1d or 2d mapped onto some
one-dimensional thing that we wanted to
know so yes/no is real early just you
know are you over a threshold or under
threshold and that's it right but what
about multi-dimensional indices where we
have much more complicated 3d 4d 5d
lookup keys that you're trying to index
and you want to do very efficient lookup
in in those situations so you know you
can imagine since machine learning
models ml models are just simply
creating these mapping functions that
they should apply for multi-dimensional
indices as well and I think the saving
could be even more dramatic in those
part use cases the other thing that I
think is worth thinking about in closing
is that the fundamental ideas in from
this lecture that I think you might be
able to take away from is that if you
learn the patterns in your data you
should be able to make use of that in
your data structure design right that's
in some extent to some extent is not
really
huge surprise and there's been other
data structure work that has make made
advantage of data patterns as well but
one thing that is really interesting
here is actually the fact that much of
the old data structure design assumes
essentially a kind of computing
architecture that's based upon CPUs and
in CPUs you know the typical operation a
lot of times is if them statements right
if this and then do this otherwise do
this other thing and you know that makes
like branching a prediction etc are very
very important in these kinds of
architectures but the thing is that
increasingly we're moving to a world
where we have vector processors where
vector matrix multiplies are really
really cheap so to some extent one of
the things that I think is much it's
really exciting about the work that
we're doing here is the realization that
maybe we won't be even running these
learning disease on CPUs we'd be running
them on vector processors where
essentially you're replacing the if-then
statements with multiplies vector
multiplies to be precise and so that
means that if every server comes with a
vector processor I still I'm I'm unlike
Alex I am Oh enough to remember the
coprocessors next to the 83 86 s right
so there was already some at some point
in our past and in computing history
where we thought that coupling a vector
processor along with with CPUs could be
a real advantage in the design and we
think that's kept the case in data
centers as well so that's it I think
that was kind of the way to to summarize
what we're thinking about in this space
and I hope that was interesting to all
of you thank you very much
you